[Music]
so i think i think what we really set
out to do with this piece was that
we really want to challenge the
the perception of waste and what's still
beautiful we actually challenge you to
see whether you can tell which other one
is made from
discarded marble and which other ones
they are made from fresh marble
and you actually start to realize that
there's actually no
discernible difference between
what is a fresh piece and a
what is shown away
it's really down to what is perceived as
waste so what is perceived as waste to
the factories may be beautiful to us i
mean we are all skeptics if i were to
see something like that i also
questioned you sure not this one is not
from the same piece man
even if people question uh
how they look
but if it gets them thinking
why not
right
i think for us
the way that we integrated was
like how
something can take on
in a sense two different states
depending on how you see it so there's
always this very interesting shift in
uh what exactly defies and constitutes
as waste
and it's always this reframing that we
are always trying to
grapple with
so
i think when this brief came and then
yeah i think like the idea of like being
able to present
a single same material in two different
ways or two different states or two
different perceptions was something that
was very fascinating to us end of the
day
i think whenever you're doing art or
design is not measured by
the outcome i think it's more about what
are you trying to raise as a question
what is so powerful about design or
is that you are able to
sometimes sitting from a different angle
maybe some people might actually
might actually overlook because you're
able to kind of question norms existing
status quo and like really come in
we think can things be done better or
done differently
so that to me is like
a very inspiring thing
how available is a piece of painting
right
it's just on the wall it's not moving
there's nothing to it but
if the artist's intent is for you to
feel in a certain way and if you walk
out of the room feeling that way
or if the intent is to make you question
yourself even more i think then it's
achieved and then that is the value
you